this is the first time we've done this
and I don't know how hard people are
gonna go I knew that if I played mind
games it would throw them off I feel
like I'm gonna have nightmares about
this challenge money race was a
professional sport hall-of-famer right
here baby
hello I've recently come into a bit of
money beautiful aren't they the mind
reels what could be purchased with such
a bounty and that's why I've enlisted
the help of three of my co-workers to
help me determine once and for all
what's the worst way I could spend my
riches let the games begin
[Music]
welcome to the great money race I'd like
to hear what's the worst thing you guys
have ever bought starting here with aria
I wanted to see you know if money can
actually buy friendship and happiness so
I actually did spend $100 on a
Craigslist ad for someone to be my
friend for a day it didn't really work
out we hung out one day never saw each
other again that is a terrible way to
spend $100 absolutely Annie what's the
worst thing you've ever bought off the
top of my head probably a zoom Shane
what's the worst thing you've ever
bought someone on my dormitory floor my
freshman year of college sold me a mouse
and I kept it for about 48 hours before
I realized you really stunk up the very
small dorm room and then I took it up to
the fourth floor and left it there and
just put a note on it that said I need a
home free mouse I think I paid $40 for
it $40 for a secondhand mouse how much
do you think of fresh Mouse costs 4
bucks
how they feed those things to snakes
left and right so yeah you all have
given me great confidence that at the
end of this all know the worst way to
spend $100 I'm going to give you each
$100 and your goal yes yeah see my eyes
are down here your job is to spend at
the hundred dollars that I give you as
poorly as you can you have two hours to
come as close to spending the total $100
as possible in no fewer than four stores
every item you buy has to be daisy
chained to the next item so the last
letter has to begin the next thing you
buy for instance if you went to the
store and bought an egg you'd have to go
to another store to buy a Gamecube the
winner will be determined entirely by me
what's at stake nothing less than my
best $100 bill it's going to break my
heart to part with her but if you can
spend $100 as poorly as I know you
it'll all been worth it and after this
you'll be back to zero you'll have zero
dollars
don't worry about my finance that's okay
I am alone I think it's time we get you
guys your money okay go let the great
money race begin what it like done
buddy-buddy done starting the great
money race now I'm just gonna head out
to some sort of mall to make it easier
on myself and hopefully some stupid is
there where's your car Shane where's
your car
Arya already given me some sass we
could've getting away from him so cute
look at me there's a movie theater near
me they should just buy a ticket to
those movies I'm pay my parking ticket
the thing I buy a lot to start with a
tea which is perfect because I need a
tie start big give myself a lot of
options and then narrow it down from
there it's money race this is the great
money race I know I'm paralyzed by
choice in the first item there's a
fishing pole gear don't know why I know
when we need that
I think we found our winner no dollar
store ties for this guy anymore oh hell
yeah I got 87 hours to go let's do it
it's money I'm a rich man that dent
wears silk eyes hello everyone
I paid 3590 for this I feel like I'm
winning I don't know how the other
people are doing but I feel like I'm
winning
vinyl ends whoops oh oh God I got a
nutcracker so that ends on our time to
get brandishes make faster by start with
it me if I'm gonna win this thing I got
to start thinking bigger numbers than
definitely what is it oh there's our
Hooters I got an idea I don't know if
this is a good idea something I maybe
regret I'd like four dollars left I'm
out of breath
I'm very sweaty Wow the pleasures that
money could buy it's calculated that I
had four dollars I have like 14 dollars
look cuz this is money rice welcome back
I hope you found the experience freeing
Shane you were the first to return you
should present first so I started out by
going to a sort of a big-box store and
the first thing that that sang to me was
patriotic Nutcracker he's wearing camo
and it's not just even the regular camo
it's that weird digital camo that they
wore in Desert Storm
what a terrible purchase yeah from there
I went down to a local grocery store so
we're working with our and there were
plenty of good treats in there but I
wanted to spend this money poorly her
head itches yeah oh and those are
fine-looking radishes they look they're
dripping these babies are dripping and
how she tastes tell it that they don't
taste I mean problem was they were a
dollar 49 you know I got to hit that
hundo I walked down to the local thrift
store because I thought now if I want to
spend a lot of money in Los Angeles
where do I have to go the thrift store
hat 39 dollars and 42 cents wow that is
way of too expensive for that hat from
there this big ol huggable guy $29.99
huh but it was 50% off which still
allowed me to have a little fun and keep
in mind this is maybe 25 minutes too
I'm I'm darting while this idiot over
here driving around in his car
Oh stuck in traffic yeah there weren't a
lot of other stores around there there
was a Supercuts so what I did is I got a
real bad haircut and that's a just a
classic bold cut huh
the woman she didn't want to give me the
haircut but I told her it was for a play
so that's putting me up at about $96
about 3 bucks remaining I went to a
local restaurant a big fast food chain
not a lot on the menu with a T but then
I saw the words triple cheeseburger and
baby that put me at $99 and 62 cents
hell that is a tremendous waste of money
shame I'll blast I don't know if I won
because this is the first time we've
done this and I don't know how hard
people are gonna go was this a little
stunt like yeah but it was a bad way to
spend money so Annie you were the next
person to return so the thing that
caught me up was that there were too
many choices the money demands burden
I got a call me buyer named vinyl Oh
very stupid purchase is that the one
where he fiddles himself with a peach he
does yes but anyway this liner was 41 99
whoa right out of the gates do you have
any sort of streaming music subscription
I do and I also don't have a vinyl
player well it was just very stupid
purchase what a waste
and so vinyl ends with an L the smallest
lipstick Oh see it's red indeed lipstick
so that gives you a K the K leads to the
mint 10 that sends Kurt do you know
anybody named Kurt I don't think I do
what a tremendously bad purchase does
anyone know any Kurt's I know a Kurt
with a C no he doesn't count
Kurt candy and then the Y I love to
yogurt that we could get for free at
work oh paid money for something that
you could have come back here gone for
free
terrific waste of money a T leads to
a truck oh this is a bad looking truck I
got a plan this is a pretty boring
looking truck that leads to no kitchen
nice that that's probably not very sharp
um which led to that's an E and E
vitamin do you have an vitamin E
deficiency no do you know what vitamin E
is it helps with eye I don't know I've
never even heard of it I don't think
I've ever heard of vitamin E either all
right certainly I'm not well your guests
till munching them radishes use one in
each hand are you gonna eat the tails
would you judge me if I did shame all
right guys okay let's keep it all on the
racetrack yeah my grand total was 96 99
96 99 so not quite as close as Shane
came that's still tremendous really a
lot of big waste of money do I think I
won I'm not confident but you know maybe
I'll be surprised Arya yes you're the
last to arrive what did you purchase I
really wanted to look at American
consumerism specifically as an allegory
to the Red Scare of the 1950's what are
you talk yes let me begin
so the first purchase was a parking
ticket uh-huh III went to Hollywood
Boulevard and of course the criminals
there the extortionists they don't offer
free parking so I had to pay $2 for
parking no validation there was
validation involved and with the tea I
purchased this very luxurious 100% silk
tie Wow
can i yes absolutely
[Music]
that's it that's incredible so it's hide
that leaves us with the need of course
one of the most beautiful childhood
icons right now Elsa of frozen lore yes
it's a movie frozen movie have you seen
the movie I see parts of no he's only
he's only heard tales of it round the
campfire but she's beautiful all right
very good so you have almost no
understanding of the frozen universe and
you bought yourself a useless action
figure from it
Elsa yeah frozen exactly a so I bought a
treat that I thought we could all enjoy
together which was which were these
airheads airheads I've never had one
before sort of like a taffy oh I did not
know there were multiple flavors either
don't look at that do you know anything
are you
airheads s and so I went into a truly
American establishment which is of
course hooters for a shirt as Americans
and we should be supporting local local
American companies where's that t-shirt
made so shirt shirt and then finally I
was there already
yeah but I thought the tea you have gone
to four different establishments saying
are you saying you doubled up at Hooters
here yeah I made it
yes I doubled up whatever your business
was now are ma asked was there a woman
who checked you out at Hooters and did
you just sort of keep lying to impress
her by si si si si she's really good
what was her name Melissa and that one
ready to go and she she really sold me
on this but and some may view this as
unnecessary this tote key for tote
girls just want to have this on first
very funny and it's funny that girls
just want to have you think that's funny
Eila okay
this is it and what's great about this
and you know is that we can put all this
in one tote bag.this Canaries I'm struck
by the fact that this journey seems to
have made you lose your mind I've never
seen you quite like this you know
sometimes you get into very deep
conversations with people you meet and
Melissa is she's a very thoughtful
person you know you guys would
understand you haven't met her
add it all together I believe came to a
nice tidy sum of that 96 49 86 49 that
puts you in the 96 percentile win or
lose I think I've come out of this with
beautiful memories as well as some
purchases that I really think will ask
me a lifetime especially this time 100%
silk this has been tremendous waste of
money no matter how you go about looking
at it aria like I said it seems like you
really lost your mind going out there
trying to buy these things any you
bought products that you'll never be
able to use a dump truck for a child
that doesn't exist
I'll call me by your name vinyl you have
no way of playing and Shayne you are
going to have to spend more money to
rectify the spending of the money that
you have where I don't because Shane
came closest and was fastest and cut his
hair to look like that Shane
congratulations you are the inaugural
winner of the great money race this is
my best $100 bill and it's yours now
very well done really a tremendous waste
of money you know clearly clearly Shane
ate one so that's why Shane wanted it
most of all he deserves that hand oh
well well well looks like it pays to be
good at money race because I won money
and I raced for it and now it's mine and
I just feel like the belle of the ball
pays to get a bowl cut that's actually
not true it doesn't ever pay to bulk up
but today it does let us know in the
comments how you would spend a hundred
dollars and don't forget to daisy-chain
your answers
[Music]
[Music]